the Bank of England does have operations
in place to make loans in all major
currencies on a weekly basis commercial
banks have already pre-positioned enough
collateral with the Bank of England to
allow them to borrow around 300 billion
pounds through these facilities now
conclude the Bank of England's actions
today comprise a timely and powerful
package to support UK businesses and
households in order to bridge a
temporarily difficult period and to
mitigate any longer lasting effects on
jobs growth and the UK economy the Bank
is coordinating its actions with those
that the Chancellor will announce later
today in the budget in order to ensure
that our initiatives are complementary
and that they will collectively have
maximum impact consistent with our
independent responsibilities the bank
will also continue to coordinate closely
with our international counterparts the
bank will take all necessary further
steps to support the UK economy and
financial system consistent with its
statutory responsibilities now some
watching will recall a financial crisis
a little more than a decade ago and then
the financial system was the core of the
problem now it can be part of the
solution over the past decade the UK
financial system has been transformed
but we didn't build this strength for
its own sake
this is prudence with a purpose its
resilience with a reason and that reason
is to fulfil the Bank of England's
mission namely to promote the good of
the people of the United Kingdom by
maintaining monetary and financial
stability by acting today the bank is
ensuring that the strength of our
financial system can be directed to
where its most needed in the months
ahead